SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The AEP is probably
one of the most difficult
concepts we talk about
in this course.
It seems simple to start with.
As I said before, it's one of
those things where you think
you understand it, and
then you think you
don't understand it.
When Shannon first came out with
this theory, there were a
lot of very, very good
professional mathematicians
who spent a long time trying
to understand this.
And who, in fact, blew it.
Because, in fact, they were
trying to look at it strictly
in terms of mathematics.
They were looking for strict
mathematical theorems, they
weren't looking to try to
get the insight from it.
Because of that they
couldn't absorb it.
There were a lot of engineers
who looked at it, and couldn't
absorb it because they couldn't
match it with any of
the mathematics, and therefore
they started thinking there
was more there then there really
was so, so this is, in
fact, tricky.
What we're looking at is a
sequence of chance variables
coming from a discrete
memoryless source.
In other words, a discrete
memoryless source is something
that spits out symbols and each
symbol is independent of
each other symbol, each symbol
has the same probability mass
function as every
other symbol.
We said it's a neat thing to
look at this log pmf random
variable, and a log pmf random
variable is minus log of the
probability of the particular
symbol.
So we have a sequence now
of random variables.
And the expected value of that
random variable, for each of
the random variables, is the
expected value of the log pmf
which is, as we said before, is
this thing we've called the
entropy, which we're trying
to get some insight into.
So we have this log pmf random
variable, we have the entropy,
which is the expected
value of it.
We then talked about
the sequence of
these random variables.
We talked about the sample
average of them, and the whole
reason you want to look at this
random variable is the
sample average of a lot of these
pmf's, since logs add
when the thing you're taking
the log of multiplies.
What you wind up with is the sum
of these log pmf's is, in
fact, equal to minus the lof
of the probability of the
whole sequence.
In other words, you look at this
whole sequence as a big,
giant chance variable, which
has capital X to the n
different possible values.
Namely, every possible
sequence of length n.
When you're talking about source
coding, you have to
find the code word for
each of those m to
the n different sequences.
So what you're doing here
is trying to look at the
probability of each of those
m to the n sequences.
We can then use Huffman coding,
or whatever we choose
to use, to try to encode
those things.
OK, the weak law of large
numbers applies here, and says
that the probability that this
sample average of the log pmf
is close to the expected
value of the log pmf.
The probability that that's
greater than or equal to
epsilon is less than or equal to
the variance of the log pmf
random variable, divided by
n times epsilon squared.
Now, we are going to take the
viewpoint that n epsilon
squared, is very small.
Excuse me, it's very large.
Epsilon we're thinking as a
small number, and we're
thinking of as a large number,
but the game we always play
here is to first pick some
epsilong, as small as you want
to make it, and then you make
n larger and larger.
And as n gets bigger and bigger,
eventually this number
gets very small.
So that's the game that
we're playing.
It's y n times epsilon squared,
we're thinking of it
is a large number.
So what this says is the
probability that this log pmf
of the entire sequence, well the
sample value of it, namely
the log pmf divided by n,
us close to H of X. The
probability of that is less
than or equal to this.
We then define the typical
set, T sub epsilon of n.
This is the set of all typical
sequences out of the source.
So we're defining typical
sequences in this way.
It's a set of all sequences
which are
what we put into there.
Well, it's what we put into
there, but we're looking at
the compliment of this set.
These are the exceptional
things.
These are the typical things.
We're saying that the
exceptional things here have a
small probability when you
make n big enough.
This is saying that the
exceptional things don't
amount to anything, and the
typical things fill up the
entire probability space.
So what were saying is the
probability that this sequence
is actually typical is greater
than or equal to 1 minus
something small.
It says when n gets big enough
the probability that you get a
typical sequence out of the
source is going to wan.
OK.
We drew this in terms of a
probability distribution,
which I hope makes things look a
little more straightforward.
This is the distribution
function of the sample average
of this log pmf random
variable.
And what we're saying is that
as n gets larger and larger,
the thing that's going to happen
because of the fact
that the variance of the sample
average -- the sample
average is always a
random variable.
The average is not a random
variable, it's a fixed number.
And what this is saying is
that as n gets larger and
larger, this distribution
function here gets closer and
closer to a stack.
In other words, the thing that's
happening is that as n
gets big, you go along here,
nothing happens suddenly you
move up here and suddenly
you move across there.
That's what happens in the
limit, mainly the sample
average is, at that point,
always equal to the average.
So as n goes to infinity,
a typical set approaches
probability 1.
We express that in terms of the
Chebyshev inequality in
this way, but the picture says
you can interpret it in any
one of a hundred
different ways.
Because the real essence of
this is not the Chebyshev
inequality, the real essence of
it is saying that as n gets
bigger and bigger,
this distribution
function becomes a stack.
So that's a nice way of
thinking about it.
Let's summarized what
we did with that.
All of the major results
about typical sets.
The first of them,
is this one.
It's a bound on the number of
elements in a typical set, I'm
not going to rederive that
again, but it comes from
looking at the fact that all of
the typical elements have
roughly the same probability.
All of them collectively fill
up the whole space, and
therefore you can find the
probability of each of them by
taking one and dividing by the
probability of each of them.
When you do that, you
get two bounds.
One of them says that this
magnitude is less than 2 to
the n times H of
X plus epsilon.
The other one says it's greater
than 2 to the n H of X
minus epsilon.
And you have to throw in this
little fudge factor here
because of the fact that the
typical set doesn't quite fill
up the whole space.
What that all says is when n
gets large the number of
typical elements is
approximately equal to 2 to
the n times H of X.
Again, think hard
about what this means.
This number here really isn't
all like 2 to the n H of X.
This n times epsilon, is going
to be a big number.
As n gets bigger, it gets
bigger and bigger.
But, at the same time, when you
look at 2 to the n times H
of X plus epsilon, and you know
that H of X is something
substantial and you know that
epsilon is very small, in some
sense it still says this.
And in source coding terms,
it very much says this.
Because in source coding terms,
what you're always
looking at is these exponents.
Because if you have n different
things you're trying
to encode, it takes you log
of n bits to encode them.
So when you take the log of
this, you see that the number
of extra bits you needs to
encode these sequences is on
the order of n times epsilon.
Which is some number of bits,
but the real number bits
you're looking at is n times
H of X. So that's the major
term, and this is just fiddly.
The next thing we found is that
the probability of an
element in a typical set is
between 2 the minus n times H
of X plus epsilon and 2
to the minus n times
H of X minus epsilon.
Which is saying almost the same
thing as this is saying.
And again, there's this
approximation which says this
is about equal to 2 to the minus
n of H of X. And this is
an approximation in exactly the
same sense that that's an
approximation.
Finally, the last statement is
that the probability that
this typical --
the probability that you get a
typical sequence is greater
than or equal to 1 minus this
variance divided by n times
epsilon squared, with the same
kind of approximation.
The probability that
you get the typical
sequence is about 1.
So what this is saying is
there are hardly any
exceptions in terms
of probability.
There are a huge number
of exceptions.
But they're all extraordinarily
small in
probability.
So most of the space is all
tucked into this typical set.
Most of these, all of these
typical sequences, have about
the same probability.
And the number of typical
sequences is about 2 to the n
times H of X.
Does that say that the entropy
has any significance?
It sure does.
Because the entropy is really
what's determining everything
about this distribution,
as far as
probabilities are concerned.
There's nothing left
beyond that.
If you're going to look at very
long sequences, and in
source coding we want
to look at long
sequences, that's the story.
So the entropy tells a story.
Despite what Huffman said.
Huffman totally ignored the idea
of entropy and because of
that he came up with the optimal
algorithm, but his
optimal algorithm didn't
tell him anything about
what was going on.
This is not the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Huffman, I think his algorithm
is one of the neatest things
I've ever seen, because
he came up
with it out of nowhere.
Just pure thought,
which is nice.
We then start to talk about
fixed lenght to fized length
source coding.
This is not a practical thing.
This is not something I would
advise trying to do.
It's something which is
conceptually useful, because
it's talks about anything you
can do eventually, when you
look at an almost infinite
sequence of symbols from the
source and you look at how
many bits it takes you to
represent them.
Ultimately you need to turn that
encoder on, at some point
in pre-history, and pre-history
in our present day
is about one year ago.
And you have to turn it off
sometime in the distant
future, which is maybe
six months from now.
During that time you have to
encode all these bits.
So, in fact, when you get it
all done and look at the
overall picture, it's fixed
length to fixed length.
And all of these algorithms
are just ways of doing the
fixed length to fixed length
without too much delay
involved in them.
I didn't say everything there.
What this typical set picture
gives us there, is you can
achieve an expected number of
bits per source symbol, which
is about n times H of X, with
very rare failures.
And if you try to achieve H of
X minus epsilon bits per
symbol, the interesting thing
we found last time, was that
the fraction of sequences you
can encode was zilch.
In other words, there is a very
rapid transition here.
If you try to get by with too
few bits per symbol, you die
very, very quickly.
It's not that your error
probability is large, your
error probability is
asymptotically equal to 1.
You always screw up.
So that's the picture.
We want to go onto
Markow sources.
Let me explain why I want
to do this first.
When we're talking about the
discrete memoryless sources,
it should be obvious that that's
totally a toy problem.
There aren't any sources I can
imagine where you would want
to encode their output where
you can reasonably conclude
that they were discrete
and memoryless.
Namely, that each symbol
was independent
of each other symbol.
The only possibility I can
think of is where you're
trying to report the results
of gambling or something.
And gambling is so dishonest
that they probably aren't
independent anyway.
You could use this is a way
of showing they aren't
independent, but it's not
a very useful thing.
So somehow we want to be able
to talk about how do you
encode sources with memory.
Well Markow sources are
the easiest kind of
sources with memory.
And they have the nice property
that you can include
as much statistics in
them as you want to.
You can make them include as
much of the structure you can
find as anything else will do.
So that people talk about much
more general classes of
sources, but these are
really sufficient.
These are sufficient to talk
about everything useful.
Not necessarily the nicest way
to think about useful things
but it's sufficient.
So a finite state in Markov
chain, I assume you're
somewhat familiar with Markov
chaings from taking a
probability courses.
If not, you should probably
review it there, because the
notes go through it
pretty quickly.
There's nothing terribly
complicated there, but a
finite state in a Markov chain
is a sequence of discrete
chance variables, in that sense
it's exactly like the
discrete memoryless sources
we were looking at.
The letters come from some
finite alphabet, so in that
sense it's like the discrete
memoryless sources.
But here the difference is that
each letter depends on
the letter before.
Namely, before the Markov chain
changes from one state
to another state in one of these
steps, it looks at the
state it's in and decides where
it's going to go next.
So we have a transition
probability matrix, you can
think of this as a matrix,
it's something which has
values for every S in the state
space, and for everys S
prime in the state space.
Which represents the probability
that the state at
time n is equal the this state
S, and the state of time n
minus 1 is equal to the
states S prime.
So this tells you what's the
probabilities are of going
from one state to another.
The important thing here is
that this single step
transition incorporates all of
the statistical knowledge.
In other words, this is also
equal to the probability that
S n is equal to this state S,
given that S n minus 1 is
equal to the state S prime, and
also that S n minus 2 is
equal to any given state of time
n minus 2, and all the
way back to S minus zero being
any old state at time S zero.
So it says that this source
loses memory, except for the
first thing back.
I like to think of this as a
blind frog who has very good
sensory perception, jumping
around on lily pads.
In other words, he can't see
the lily pad, he can only
sense the nearby lily pads.
So he jumps from one lily pad
to the next and when he gets
to the next lily pad, he then
decides which lily pad he's
going go to go to next.
That'll wake you up, anyway.
And we also want to define
some initial pmf on the
initial state.
So you like to think of Markov
chains as starting at some
time and then proceeding forever
into the future.
That seems to indicate that all
we've done is to replace
one trivial problem with another
trivial problem.
In other words, on step memory
is not enough to deal with
things like English text
and things like that.
Or any other language
that you like.
So the idea of a Markov source
is that you create whatever
set of states that you want,
you can have a very large
state space, but you associate
the output of the source not
with the states, but with
the transitions from
one state to another.
So this gives an example of it,
it's easier to explain the
idea by simply looking
at an example.
In this particular example,
which I think is the same as
the one in the notes, what
you're looking at is a memory
of the two previous states.
So this is a binary source, it
produces binary digits, just
either zero or 1.
If the previous two digits were
zero zero, it says that
the next digit is going to be
a 1 with probability 0.1 and
the next is going to be a zero
with probability 0.9.
If you're in states 0,0 and the
next thing that comes out
is a zero, then at that point,
namely at that point one
advanced into the future, you
have a zero as your last
digit, a zero as a previous
digit, and a zero as the digit
before that.
So your state has move from xn
minus 2 and xn minus 1, to xn
minus 1 and xn.
In other words, any time you
make a transition, this digit
here, which is the previous
digit, has to always become
that digit.
You'll notice the same thing
in all of these.
When you go from here to there,
this last digit becomes
the first digit.
When you go from here to here,
the last digit because the
first digit, and so forth.
And that's a characteristic of
this particular structure of
having the memory represented
by the last two digits.
So the kind of output you can
get from this source --
I mean you see that it doesn't
do anything very interesting.
When you have two zeroes in the
past, it tends to produce
a lot more zeroes, it tends to
get stuck with lots of zeroes.
If you got a single 1 that goes
over into this state, and
from there it can either
go there or there.
Once it gets here, it tends to
produce a large number of 1's.
So what's happening here is you
have a Markov chain which
goes from long sequences of
zeroes, to transition regions
where there are a bunch of zeros
and 1's, and finally
gets trapped into either the all
zero state again, or the
all 1 state again.
And moves on from there.
So the letter is what's in this
case the source output.
If you know the old state, the
source output specifies in
this state.
If you know the old state and
the new state, that specifies
the letter.
In other words, one of the
curious things about this
chain is I've arranged it so
that, since we have a binary
output, they're only
two possible
transitions from each state.
Which says that the state plus
the sequence of source outputs
specifies the state at every
point in time, the stayed at
every point in time specifies
the source sequence.
In other words, the two are
isomorphic to each other.
One specifies the other.
Since one specifies the other,
you can pretty much forget
about the sequence and
look at the state
chain, if you want to.
And therefore everything you
know about Markov chains is
useful here.
Or if you like to think about
the real source, you can think
about the real source as
producing these letters.
So either way is fine
because either one
specifies the other.
When you don't have that
property, and you look at a
sequence of letters from this
source, these are called
partially specified
Markov chains.
And they're awful things
to deal with.
You can write theses about, but
you don't get any insight
about them.
There's hardly anything that
you would like to be true
which is true.
And these are just awful
things to look at.
So we won't look them.
One of the nice things about
engineering is you can create
your own models.
Mathematicians have to look
at the crazy models that
engineers suggest to them.
They have no choice.
That's their job.
But as an engineer, we can only
look at the nice models.
We can play and the
mathematicians have to work.
So it's nicer to be an
engineer, I think.
Although famous mathematicians
only look at the engineering
problems that appeal to them,
so in fact, when they become
famous the two groups come
back together again.
Because the good engineers are
also good mathematician, so
they become sort of
the same group.
These transitions, mainly the
transition lines that we draw
on a graph like this, always
indicate positive probability.
In other words, that there's
zero probability from going to
here to here.
You don't clutter up the diagram
by putting a line in,
which allows you to just look at
these transitions to figure
out what's going on.
One of the things that you
learned when you study finite
state Markov chains, is that a
state s is accessible from
some other state s prime, if the
graph has some path from s
prime to s.
In other words, it's not
saying you can go
there in one step.
It's saying that there's some
way you can get there if you
go long enough.
Which means there's some
probability of getting there.
And the fact that there's a
probability of getting there
pretty much means that you're
going to get there eventually.
That's not an obvious statement
but let's see what
that means here.
This state is accessible from
this state, in the sense that
you can get from here to there
by going over here and then
going to here.
If we look at the states which
are accessible from each
other, you get some set of
states, and if you're in that
set of states, you can
never get out of it.
Therefore, every one of those
states remains with positive
probability and you keep
rotating back and forth
between them in some way, but
you never get out of them.
In other words, a Markov chain
which doesn't have this
property would be the following
Markov chain.
That's the simplest one
I can think of.
If you start out in this
state you stay there.
If you start out in this state,
you stay there, That's
not a very nice chain.
Is this a decent model for
an engineering study?
No.
Because when you're looking at
engineering, the thing that
you're interested in, is you're
looking at something
that happens over a long
period of time.
Back at time infinity you can
decide whether you're here, or
whether you're here, and you
might as well not worry a
whole lot about what happened
back at time minus infinity,
as far as building your model.
You may as well just build a
model for this, or build a
model for that.
There's another thing here,
which is periodicity.
In some chains, you can go from
this state to this state
in one step, well
one, two steps.
Or you can go there in one,
two, three, four steps.
Or you can go there in one, two,
three steps and so forth.
Which says, in terms of m the
period of s is the greatest
common denominator
of path lengths
from s back to s again.
If that period is equal to 1,
mainly if there's not some
periodic structure which says
the only way you can get back
to a state is by coming back
every two steps or every three
steps or something, then
again it's not a
very nice Markov chain.
Because if you're modeling it,
you might as well just model
things over two states instead
of over single states.
So the upshot of that is you
define these nice Markov
chains, which are aperiodic,
which don't have any of this
periodic structure, and every
state is accessible from every
other state.
And you call them ergodic
Markov chains.
And what ergodic means, sort
of and as a more general
principle, is that the
probabilities of things are
equal to the relative
frequency of things.
Namely, if you look at a very
long sequence of things out of
a Markov chain, what you see
in that very long sequence
should be representative of the
probabilities of that very
long sequence.
The probabilities of transitions
at various times
should be the same from
one time to another.
And that's whate ergodicity
means.
It means that the thing
is stationery.
You look at it at one time, it
behaves the same way as at
another time.
It doesn't have any periodic
structure, which means if you
look at it at even times, it
behaves differently from
looking at it at odd times.
That's the kind of Markov chain
you would think you
would have, unless you look at
these odd ball examples of
other things.
Everything we do is going to
be based on the idea of
ergodic Markov chains,
because they're the
nicest models to use.
A Markov source then is
a sequence of labeled
transitions on an and ergodic
Markov chain.
Those are the only things
we want to look at.
But that's general enough
to do most of the
things we want to do.
And once you have ergodic Markov
chains, there are a lot
of nice things that happen.
Mainly, if you try to solve this
set of equations, namely
if you want to say, well suppose
there is some pmf
function which gives
me the relative
frequency of a given state.
Namely, if I look at an enormous
number of states, I
would like the state little
s to come up with
some relative frequency.
All the time that I do it.
Namely, I wouldn't like to have
one sample path which
comes up with a relative
frequency 1/2, and another
sample path of almost infinite
length which comes up with a
different relative frequency.
Because it would mean that
different sequences of states
are not typical of
the Markov chain.
That's another way of looking
at what ergodicity means.
It means that infinite
length sequences
are not typical anymore.
It depends on when they
start, when they stop.
It depends on whether
you start at an even
time or an odd time.
Depends on all of these things,
that -- all of these
things that real sources
shouldn't depend on.
So, if you have relative
frequencies then you should
have those relative frequencies
at time n and at
time n minus 1.
And probability of a particular
symbol s, if the
probabilities of the previous
symbol s prime were the same
values, q of s prime.
We know the transition
probabilities, that's q of s
given s prime.
The sum over s prime, of q of s
prime, given capital Q of s
given s prime, what is that?
That's the probability of x.
In other words, if you start
out at time n minus 1 with
something pmf function on the
states at time n minus 1, this
is the formula you would use to
calculate the probability
the pmf function for
states at time s.
This is the probability mass
function for the states at the
next unit of time, time n.
If this probability distribution
is the same as
this probability distribution,
then you say that you're in
steady state, because you do
this again, you plug this into
here, it's the same thing.
You get the same answer
at time n plus 1.
You plug it in again you got the
same answer at time n plus
2, and so on forever.
So you stay in steady state.
The question is, if you have a
matrix here, can you solve
this equation?
Is it easy to solve?
And what's the solution?
There's a nice theorem that
says, if the chain is ergodic,
namely if it has these nice
properties of transition
probabilities, that corresponds
to a particular
kind of matrix here.
If you have that kind of matrix,
this is just a vector
matrix equation.
That vector matrix equation has
a unique solution then for
this probability little q, in
terms of this transition
probability.
It also has the nice property
that if you start out with any
old distribution, and you grind
this thing away for a
number of times, this q of x
is going to approach the
steady state solution.
Which means if you start a
Markov chain out in some known
state, after awhile the
probability that you're in
state s is going to become this
steady state probability.
It gets closer and closer
to it exponentially
as time goes on.
So that's just arithmetic.
These steady state probabilities
are approached
asymptotically from any starting
state, i.e. for all s
and s prime and s.
The limit of the probability
that s sub n, the state at
time n, is equal to a given
state s, given that the state
at time zero was equal
to s prime.
This probability is equal to q
of s and the limit as n goes
to infinity.
All of you know those things
from studying Markov chains.
I hope, because those
are the main facts
about Markov chains.
Incidentally I'm not
interested in
Markov chains here.
We're not going to do anything
with them, the only thing I
want to do with them is to show
you that there are ways
of modeling real sources, and
coming as close to good models
for real sources as
you want to come.
That's the whole
approach here.
How do you do coding
for Markov sources?
The simplest approach, which
doesn't work very well, is to
use a separate prefix-free code
for each prior state.
Namely, if I look at this Markov
chain that I had, it
says that when I'm in the state
I want to somehow encode
the next state that I go to, or
the next letter that comes
out of the Markov source.
The things that can come out
of the Markov source are
either a 1 or a zero.
Now you see the whole problem
with this approach.
As soon as you look at an
example, it sort of blows the
cover on this.
What's the best prefix-free code
to encode a 1 and a zero?
Where one appears with
probability 0.9 and the other
one appears with probability
0.1.
What's the Huffman encoder do?
It assigns one of those symols
to 1 and one of them to zero.
You might as well encode
1 to this one, and
zero to that one.
Which means that all of the
theory, all it does is
generate the same symbols
that you had before.
You're not doing any
compression at all.
It's a nice thing
to think about.
In other words, by thinking
about these things you then
see the solution.
And our solution before to these
problems was that if you
don't get anywhere by using a
prefix-free code on a single
digit, take a block of n digits
and use a prefix-free
code there.
So that's the approach
we will take here.
The general idea for single
letters is this prefix-free
code we're going to generate
satisfies a Kraft inequality,
you can use the Huffman
algorithm, you get this
property here.
And this entropy, which is now
a function of the particular
state that we were in to
start with, is just
this entropy here.
So this is a conditional
entropy, which we get a
different conditional
entropy for each
possible previous state.
And that conditional entropy
for each possible previous
state, is what tells us exactly
what we can do as far
as generating a Huffman code
for that next state.
This would work fine if you had
a symbol alphabet of size
10,000 or something.
It just doesn't work
well when your
symbol alphabet is binary.
If we start out in a steady
state, then all of these
probability stay in
steady state.
When we look at the number of
binary digits per source
symbol and we average them
over all of the initial
states, the initial states
occur with these
probabilities q of s.
We have these best
Huffman code.
So the number of binary digits
we're using per source symbol
is really this average here.
Because this is averaging
over all the states
you're going to go into.
And the entropy of the source
output, conditional on the
chance variable s, is now,
in fact, defined
just as that average.
So they encoder transmits s
zero, followed by the code
word for s 1 using s zero.
That specifies s 1, and
then you encode x 2,
using s 1 and so forth.
And the decoder is sitting there
and the decoder does
exactly the same thing.
Namely, the decoder first sees
what s zero is, then it uses
the code for s zero to decide
what x 1 was, then it uses the
code for s 1, which is
determined by s 1, s one is
determined by x 1, and it goes
on and on like that.
Let me review a little bit about
conditional entropy.
I'm going pretty fast here and
I'm not deriving these things
because they're in the notes.
And it's almost as if I want
you to get some kind of a
pattern sensitivity to these
things, without the idea that
we're going to use them a lot.
You ought to have a general idea
of waht the results are.
We're not going to spend a lot
of time on this because, as I
said before, the only thing I
want you to recognize is that
if you ever want to model a
source, this, in fact, gives
you a general way of doing it.
So this general entropy then is
using what we had before.
It's the sum over all the
states, and the sum over all
of the source outputs of these
log pmf probabilities.
This general entropy of both a
symbol and a state is equal to
this combined thing.
Which is equal, not
surprisingly, to the entropy
of the state.
Namely, first you want to know
what the state is that has
this entropy.
And then given the state, this
is the entropy of the next
letter, conditional
on the state.
Since this joint entropy is less
than or equal to H of s
plus H of x, I think you just
proved that in the homework,
didn't you?
I hope so.
That says that the entropy of
x conditional on s, is less
than or equal to the entropy of
x, which is not surprising.
It says that if you use the
previous state in trying to do
source encoding, you're going
to do better than if
you don't use it.
I mean the whole theory
would be pretty
stupid if you didn't.
That's what that says.
As I told you before, the only
way we can make all of this
work is to use
n-to-variable-length codes for
each state.
In other words, you encode n
letters at the same time.
If you look at the entropy of
the first n states given a
starting state, turns out to
be n times H of x given s.
By the same kind of rule that
you were using before.
The same argument that you
used to show that this is
equal to that, you can use to
show that this is equal to H
of S 1, given S zero, plus H of
S 2, given S 1, plus H of S
3, given S 2 and so forth.
And by the stationarity that
we have here, these are all
equal, so you wind up
with n times times
this conditional entropy.
And since the source outputs
specified the states, and the
states specified the source
outputs, you can then convince
yourself that this entropy is
also equal to n times H of X,
given S. And once you do that,
you're back in the same
position we were in when we
looked at n-to-variable-length
coding when we were looking at
discrete memoryless sources.
Namely, the only thing that
happens when you're looking at
n-to-variable length coding,
is it that one fudge factor
becomes a 1 over n.
When you have a small symbol
space by going two blocks, you
get rid of this, you can make
the expected length close to H
of X, given S. Which means, in
fact, that all of the memory
is taking into account and it
still is this one parameter,
the entropy, that
says everything.
The AEP holds --
I mean if you want to, you can
sit down and just see that it
holds, once you see what these
entropies are, I mean the
entropy you're using log pmf's,
you're just looking at
products of probabilities, which
are sums of log pmf's,
and everything is the
same as before.
And again, if you're using
n-to-variable-length codes,
you just can't achieve an
expected length less than H of
X, given S. So H of X, given
S gives the whole story.
You should read those notes,
because I've gone through that
very, very fast, partly because
some of you are
already very familiar with
Markov chains some of you are
probably less familiar with it,
so you should check that
out a little bit on your own.
I want to talk about the
Lempel Ziv universal
algorithm, which was rather
surprising to many people.
Jacob Ziv is one of the
great theorists
of information theory.
Before this time, he wrote
a lot of very,
very powerful papers.
Which were quite hard to
read in many cases.
So it was a real surprise to
people when he came up with
this beautiful idea, which was
a lovely, simple algorithm.
Some people, because of that,
thought it was Abe Lempel, who
spends part of his year at
Brandeis, who was really the
genius behind it.
In fact, it wasn't Abe Lempel,
it was Jacob Ziv who was the
genius behind it.
Abe Lempel was pretty much the
one who really implemented it,
because once you see what the
algorithm is, it's still not
trivial to try to find how
to implement it in a
simple, easy way.
If you look at all the articles
about it, the authors
are Ziv and Lempel, instead of
Lempel and Ziv, so why it got
called Lempel Ziv is a
mystery to everyone.
Anyway, they came up with
two algorithms.
One which they came up with in
1977, and people looked at
their 1977 algorithm and said,
oh that's much too complicated
to implement.
So they went back to the drawing
board, came up with
another one in 1978, which
people said, ah, we can
implement that.
So people started implementing
the LZ78 and of course, by
that time, all the technology
was much better.
You could do things faster and
cheaper then you could before,
and what happened then is that
a few years after that people
were implementing LZ77,
which turned out
to work much better.
Which is often the way
this field works.
People do something interesting
theoretically,
people say, no you can't do
it, so they simplify it,
thereby destroying some of
its best characteristics.
And then a few years later
people are doing the more
sophisticated thing, which they
should have started out
doing at the beginning.
What is a Universal Data
Compression algorithm?
A Universal Data Compression
algorithm, is an algorithm
which doesn't have any
probabilities tucked into it.
In other words, the algorithm
itself simply looks at a
sequence of letters from
an alphabet, and
encodes it in some way.
And what you would like to be
able to do is somehow measure
what the statistics are, and
at the same time as you're
measuring the statistics, you
want to encode the digits.
You don't care too
much about delay.
In fact, one way to do this --
I mean, if you're surprised
that you can build a good
universal encoder,
you shouldn't be.
Because you could just take the
first million letters out
of the source, go through all
the statistical analysis you
want to, model the source in
whatever way makes the best
sense to you, and then build a
Huffman encoder, which, in
fact, encodes things according
to that model that you have.
Of course you then have to send
the decoder the first
million digits, and the decoder
goes through the same
statistical analysis, and
therefore finds out what code
you're going to use, and then
the encoder encodes, the
decoder decodes and you have
this million symbols of
overhead in the algorithm, that
if you use the algorithm
for a billion letters instead of
a million letters, then it
all works pretty well.
So there's a little bit of
that flavor here, but the
other part of it is, it's
a neat algorithm.
And the algorithm measures
things in a faster way then
you would believe.
And as you look at it later
you say, gee, this makes a
great deal of sense even if
there isn't much statistical
structure here.
In other words, you can show
that if the source really is a
Markov source, then this
algorithm will behave just as
well, asymptotically, as the
best algorithm you can design
for that Markov source.
Namely, it's so good that it
will in fact measure the
statistics in that Markov model
and implement them.
But it does something
better than that.
And the thing which is better
is that, if you're going to
look at this first million
symbols and your objective
then is to build a Markov model,
after you build the
Markov model for that million
symbols, one of the things
that you always question about
is, should I have used a
Markov model or should I have
used some other kind of model?
And that's a difficult
question to ask.
You go through all of the
different possibilities, and
one of the nice things about the
Lempel Ziv algorithm is,
in a sense, it just does
this automatically.
If there's some kind of
statistical structure there,
it's going to find it.
If it's not Markov, if it's some
other kind of structure,
it will find it.
The question is how does it
find this statistical
structure without knowing what
kind of model you should use
to start with?
And that's the genius of things
which are universal,
because they don't assume that
you have to measure particular
things in some model that
you believe in.
It just does the whole
thing all at once.
If it's running along and the
statistics change, bing, it
changes, too.
And suddenly it will start
producing more binary digits
per source symbol, or fewer,
because that's
what it has to do.
And that's just the
way it works.
But it does have all these
nice properties.
It has instantaneous
decodability.
In a sense, it is a prefix-free
code, although you
have to interpret
pretty carefully
what you mean by that.
We'll understand that
in a little bit.
But in fact, it does do all
of these neat things.
And there are better algorithms
out there now,
whether they're better in terms
of the trade-off between
complexity and compressability,
I don't know.
But anyway, the people who do
research on these things have
to have something to
keep them busy.
And they have to have some kind
of results to get money
for, and therefore they claim
that the new algorithms are
better than the old
algorithms.
And they probably are,
but I'm not sure.
Anyway, this is a very
cute algorithm.
So what you're trying to do
here, the objective, one
objective which is achieved, is
if you observe the output
from the given probability
model, say a Markov source,
and I build the best code I can
for that Markov source,
then we know how many bits
we need per symbol.
Number of bits we need per
symbol is this entropy of a
letter of a symbol
given the state.
That's the best we can do.
How well does the Lempel
Ziv algorithm do?
Asymptotically, when you make
everything large it will
encode using a number of bits
per symbol, which is H of X,
given S. So it'll do just as
well as the best thing does
which happens to know the
model to start with.
As I said before the algorithm
also compresses in the absence
of any ordinary kind of
statistical structure.
Whatever kind of structure
is there, this
algorithm sorts it out.
It should deal with gradually
changing statistics.
It does that also, but perhaps
not in the best way.
We'll talk about that later.
Let's describe it
a little bit.
If we let x 1, x 2 blah blah
blah, be the output of the
source, and the alphabet is some
alphabet capital X, which
has size m, let's just as
notation, let x sub m super n
denote the string xm,
xm plus 1, up to xn.
In other words, in describing
this algorithm we are, all the
time talking about strings of
letters taken out of this
infinite length string that
comes out of the source.
We want to have a nice notation
for talking about a
sub string of the
actual sequence.
We're going to use a window
in this algorithm.
We want the window to have a
size with the power of 2.
Typical values for the window
range from about a thousand up
to about a million.
Maybe they're even bigger
now, I don't know.
But as we'll see later, there's
some constraints there.
What the Lempel Ziv algorithm
does, this LZ77 algorithm, is
it matches the longest string
of yet unencoded -- this is
unencoded also, isn't it,
that's simple enough --
of yet unencoded symbols
by using strings
starting in the window.
So it takes this sequence of
stuff we haven't observed yet,
it tries to find the longest
string starting there which it
can match with something that's
already in the window.
If it can find something which
matches with something in the
window, what does it do?
It's going to first say how long
the match was, and then
it's going to say where in
the window it found it.
And the decoder is sitting
there, the decoder has this
window which it observes also,
so the decoder can find the
same match which is
in the window.
Why does it work?
Well, it works because with all
of these AEP properties
that we're thinking of, you tend
to have typical sequences
sitting there in the window.
And you tend to have typical
sequences which come out of
the source.
So the thing we're trying to
encode is some typical
sequence --
well you can you can think of
short typical sequences and
longer typical sequences.
We try to find the longest
typical sequence that we can.
And we're looking back into
this window, and there are
enormous number of typical
sequences there.
If we make the typical sequences
short enough, there
aren't too many of them, and
most of them are sitting there
in the window.
This'll become clearer
as we go.
Let's go on and actually
explain what
the algorithm does.
So here's the algorithm.
First, you take this large W,
this large window size, and
we're going to encode the
first thought W symbols.
We're not even going to use any
compression, that's just
lost stuff.
So we encode this first million
symbols, we grin and
bear it, and then the decoder
has this window
of a million symbols.
We at the encoder have this
window of a million symbols,
and we proceed from there.
So it gets amortized,
so we don't care.
So we then have a pointer, and
we set the pointer to W.
So the pointer is the last
thing that we encoded.
So we have all this encoded
stuff starting at time P,
everything beyond there
is as yet unencoded.
That's the first step
in the algorithm.
So far, so good.
The next step is to find the
largest n, greater than or
equal to 2, I'll explain why
greater than or equal to 2
later, such that the string x
sub p plus 1 up to p plus n,
what is that?
It's the string which starts
right beyond the pointer,
namely the string that starts
here, what we're trying to do
is find the largest n, in other
words the longest string
starting here, which we can
match with something that's in
the window.
Now we look at a, a is in the
window, we look at a b, a b as
in the window.
We look at a b a, a b a as in
the window. a b a b, a b a b
is not in the window.
At least I hope it's not in the
window or I screwed up.
Yeah, it's not in the window.
So the longest thing we can find
which matches with what's
in the window is this match
of length three.
So this is finding the longest
match which matches with
something here.
This next example, I think
the only way I can regard
that is as a hack.
It's a kind of hack that
programmers like.
It's very mysterious, but it's
also the kind of hack that
mathematicians like because in
this case this particular hack
makes the analysis
much easier.
So this is another
kind of match.
It's looking for the longest
string here,
starting at this pointer.
a b a b so forth, which matches
things starting here.
Starting somewhere
in the window.
So it finds a match a
b here. a b a here.
But now it looks for a b
a b, a match of four.
Where do we find it?
We can start back here, which
is still in the window, and
what we see is a b a b.
So these four digits match
these four digits.
Well you might say foul ball,
because if I tell you there's
a match of four and I tell you
where it is, in fact, all the
poor decoder knows is this.
If I tell you there's a match
of four and it starts here,
what's the poor decoder
going to do?
The poor decoder says, ok, so
a is that digit two digits
ago, so that gives me the a.
So I know there's an a
there. b is the next
digit, so b is there.
And then I know the first two
digits beyond the window, and
therefore this third digit is a,
so that must be that digit.
The fourth digit is
this digit, which
must be that digit.
OK?
If you didn't catch that, you
can just think about it, it'll
become clear.
I mean it really is a hack.
It's not very important.
It won't change the way
this thing bahaves.
But it does change the
way you analyze it
So that's the first
thing you do, you
look for these matches.
Next thing we're going to do
is we're going to try to
encode the matches.
Namely, we're going to try to
encode the thing the we found
in the window.
How do we encode what we
found in the window?
Well the first thing we
have to do -- yeah?
AUDIENCE: What if you don't
find any matches?
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
talk about that later.
If you don't find any matches,
I mean what I was looking for
was matches of two or more.
If you don't find any matches of
two or more, what you do is
you just take the first letter
in the window and you encode
that without any compression.
I mean our strategy here is to
always send the length of the
match first.
If you say the length of the
match is one, than the decoder
knows to look for uncompressed
symbols, instead of looking
for something in the window.
So it takes care of the case
where there haven't been any
occurrences of symbol anywhere
in the window.
So you only look for matches
of length two or more.
So then you use something called
a unary-binary code.
Theoriticians always copy
everybody else's work.
The unary-binary code was due
to Peter Elias, who was the
head of this department
for a long time.
He just died about
six months ago.
He was here up until
his death.
He used to organize department
colloquia.
He was so essential that since
he died, nobody's taken over
the department colloquia.
He was my thesis adviser, so I
tend to think very kindly of
him And he was lots
of other things.
But anyway, he invented this
unary-binary code, which is a
way of encoding the integers,
which has a lot of nice
properties.
And they're universal
properties, as you will see.
The idea is to encode the
integers, there are infinite
number of integers.
What you'd like to do, somehow
or other, is have shorter code
words for lower integers,
and longer code
words for longer integers.
In this particular Lempel Ziv
algorithm, it's particularly
important to have the lenght of
the code words growing as
the logarithm of n.
Because then anytime you find
a really long match, and you
got a very large n, you're
encoding a whole lot of
letters, and therefore you
don't care if there's an
overhead which is proportional
to log n.
So you don't mind that.
And if there's a very small
number of letters encoded, you
want something very
efficient then.
So it does that.
And the way it does it is, first
you generate a prefix,
and then you have a
representation in base 2.
Namely base 2 expansion.
So the number n, the prefix
here, I think I said it here,
the positive integer n is
encoded into the binary
representation of n, preceded by
a prefix of integer part of
log to the base 2 of n zero.
Now what's the integer part
of log to the base 2 of 1?
Log to the base 2
of 1 is zero.
It was a prefix of zero zeros.
So zero zeros is nothing.
So the prefix is nothing, the
expansion of 1, in a base 2
expansion or any other
expansion, is 1.
So the code word for 1 is 1.
If you have the number 2, log
to the base 2 of 2 is 1.
The integer part of 1 is 1, so
you start out with a single
zero and then you have
the expansion, 2 is
expanded as 1 zero.
And so forth.
Oh and then 3 is expanded as 1
1, again with a prefix of 1.
Four is encoded as
1 zero zero, blah
blah blah and so forth.
Why don't you just leave
the prefix out?
Anybody figure out why I
need the prefix there?
AUDIENCE: If without those
prefixes, you don't a
prefix-free code.
PROFESSOR: Yeah Right.
If I left them out, everything
would start with 1.
I would get to the 1, I would
say, gee, is that the end of
it or isn't it the end of it?
I wouldn't know.
But with this, if I see 1, the
only code word that starts
with 1 is this one.
If it's 2 or 3, it starts with
zero and then there's a 1,
which says it's on that next
branch which has probably 1/4.
I have a 1 0, 1 1, a prefix of
0 0, followed by a 1, put me
off on another branch.
And so forth.
So, yes, this is a
prefix-free code.
And it's a prefix-free code
which has this nice property
that the number of digits in the
code word is approximately
2 times log n.
Namely, it goes up
both ways here.
The number of zeros I need is
log to the base 2 of n.
The number of digits in the base
2 expansion, is also the
integer part of log to
the base 2 of n.
So it works both ways.
And there's always this
1 in the middle.
Again, it's a hack.
It's a hack that works
very nicely when you
try to analyze this.
OK so if the size of the match
is bigger than one, we're
going to encode the positive
integer u.
u was where the match
occurred.
How far back do you have
to count before
you find this match?
You're going to encode that
integer u into a fixed length
code of length log of w bits.
In other words, you
have a window of
size 2 to the twentieth.
You can encode any point in
there with 20 binary digits.
The 20 binary digits say how far
do you have to go back to
find this code word.
So first we're encoding n, by
this unary-binary code, then
we're encoding w just with
this simple minded way of
encoding log w bits.
And that tells us where
the match is.
The decoder goes back, there
finds the match, pumps it out
if n is equal to 1, here's the
answer to your question, you
encode the single letter
without compression.
And that takes care of the case,
either where you have a
match to that single letter,
or there isn't any match to
the single letter.
The next thing, as you might
imagine, is you set the
pointer to P plus n, because
you've encoded n digits, and
you go to step two.
Namely, you keep iterating
forever.
Until the source wears out, or
until the encoder wears out,
or until the decoder
wears out.
You just keep going.
That's all the algorithm is.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you throw out
the first n bits, when you
reset the pointer, because you
only have w bits that say
where n was for the
next iteration?
PROFESSOR: No, I throw out the
n oldest bits in the window.
AUDIENCE: Well, those are
the first n bits.
PROFESSOR: Yes the first n bits
out of the window and I
keep all of the more
recent bits.
I tend to think of the first
ones as the things closest to
the pointer, but you think of it
either way, which is fine.
So as you do it, the window
keeps sliding along.
That's what it does.
Why do you think this works?
/ There's a half
analysis in the notes.
i'd like to say a little bit
about how that analysis is
cheating, because it's not
quite a fair analysis.
If you look at the window, there
are w different starting
points in the window.
So let's write this down.
w starting points.
So for any given n, there
are there are w
springs of length n.
We don't know how long this
match is going to be, but what
I would like to do, if I'm
thinking of a Markov source,
is to say, OK, let's make n
large enough so that the size
of the typical set is about w.
ok
So choose n to be about w
divided by H of X given S. And
the size of the typical set is
then going to be 2 to the n,
wait a minute.
n is equal to log w.
So the size of the typical set
then is T sub epsilon, is
going to be roughly from what we
said 2 to the n times H of
X given S. So what I'm going to
do is to set w equal to T
of epsilon.
I'm going to focus on a match
length which I'm hoping to
achieve, of log w over H of X
given S. The typical set,
then, is a size 2 to the n times
H of x give S. And if
the typical set is of this size,
and I look at these w
strings in the window, yeah,
I'm going to have some
duplicates but roughly I'm going
to have a large enough
number of things in the window
to represent all of these
typical strings.
Or most of them.
If I try to choose an n which is
a little bigger than that,
let's call this n star.
If I try to make n a little bit
bigger than this typical
match size, I don't have a
prayer of a chance, because
the typical set then is just
very much larger than w, so
I'd be very, very lucky if I
found anything in the window.
So that can't work.
If I make n a good deal smaller,
then I'm going to
succeed with great probability
it seems, because I'm even
allowing for many, many
duplicates of each of these
typical sets to be
in the window.
So what this is saying is
there ought to be some
critical length when the
window was very large,
critical match length, and most
of the time the match is
going to be somewhere around
this value here.
And as w becomes truly
humongous, and as the match
size becomes large --
you remember for these typical
sets to make any sense, this
number has to be large.
And when this number gets large,
the size of the typical
set it humongous.
Which says, that for this
asymptotic analysis, a window
of 2 to the twentieth, probably
isn't nearly big enough.
So the asymptotic analysis is
really saying, when you have
really humongous windows
this is going to work.
You don't make windows that
large, so you have to have
some faith that this theoretical
argument is going
to work here.
But that tells you roughly what
the size of these matches
is going to be.
If the size of the matches is
that, and you use log w bits
plus 2 log n bits, to encode
each match, what happens?
Encode match.
You use log w, plus
2 log n star.
That's the number of bits it
takes you, this is the number
of bits it takes you to encode
what the match size is.
You still have to encode that.
This is the number of bits it
takes you to encode where the
match occurs.
Now how big is this
relative to this?
Well n star is on the order of
log w, so we're taking log w
plus 2 times log of log of w.
So in an approximate analysis,
you say, I don't even care
about that.
You wind up with encoding
a match with log w bits.
So you encode n star bits, you
use log w bits to do it, how
many bits are you using
per symbol?
H of X given S. That's roughly
the idea of why the Lempel Ziv
algorithm works.
Can anybody spot any problems
with that analysis?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You don't know the
probabilities beforehand, so
how do you pick w?
PROFESSOR: Good one.
You picked w by saying, I have
a computer which will go at a
certain speed.
My data rate is coming in at a
certain speed, and I'm going
to pick w as large as
I can keep up with.
With the best algorithm
I can think of for
doing string matching.
And string matching a hard thing
to do, but it's not a
terribly easy thing
to do either.
So you make w as large
as you can.
And if it's not large
enough, tough.
You got matches which are
somewhat smaller -- all this
argument about typical sets
still work except for the
epsilon and deltas that
are tucked into there.
So it's just that the epsilons
and the deltas get too big
when you're strings are
not long enough.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So your w is just
make your processing time
equal the time [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's what the determines w.
It's how fast you can do a
string search over this long,
long window.
You're not going to just search
everything one by one,
you're going to build some kind
of data structure there
that makes these searches
run fast.
Can anybody think of why
you might not want
to make w too large?
This isn't a theoretical
reason, this is
more practical thing.
AUDIENCE: Is it if the
probabilities change, it's
slow to react to
those changes?
PROFESSOR: If the probabilities
change, it's
slow to react to them, because
it's got this humongous window
here, and it's not until the
window fills up with all of
this new stuff, that it
starts to work well.
And before it fills up, you're
using an effective small
window, but you're using a
number of bits which is
proportionate to log of a large
window, and therefore
you're wasting bits.
So another thing that that
determines how big you
want w to be --
I mean the main thing that's
determines it is just that you
can't run that fast.
Because you'd like to
make it pretty big.
Another question.
How about this matter of wasting
w symbols at the
beginning to fill
up the window?
what do you do about that?
I mean, that's a pretty
stupid thing, right?
Anybody suggest a solution
to that?
If you're building this
yourself, how
would you handle it?
It's the same argument as if
the statistics change in
mid-stream.
I mean, you don't measure that
the statistics have changed,
and throw out what's
in the window.
What?
AUDIENCE: Can you not assume
that you already have a
typical sequence?
PROFESSOR: Yes, and you
don't care whether
it's right or wrong.
You could assume that the
typical sequence is all zeros,
so you fill up the window
with all zeros.
The decoder also fills it up
with all zeros, because this
is the way you always start.
And then you just start running
a log, looking for
matches and encoding things.
And as w builds up, you
start matching things.
You could even be smarter, and
know that you're window wasn't
very big and let your
window grow also.
If you wanted to really
be fancy about this.
So if you want to encode this
you can have a lot of fun, and
a lot of people over the years
have had a lot of fun trying
to encode these things.
It's a neat thing to do.